deux mois pour négocier c'est le délai
accordé par le gouvernement australien à
facebook et google le but fixé
contractuellement la rémunération des
médias locaux pour la reprise de leur
contenu par les plateformes numériques
un compromis dont se satisfont les
autorités australiennes
facebook s'est engagé à entamer des
négociations de bonne foi avec les
entreprises australiennes de médias
d'information afin de conclure des
accords pour le paiement des contenus
sont des questions importantes parce que
l'objectif du projet de loi et les
intentions du gouvernement morrison ont
toujours été conçu pour soutenir le
journalisme d'intérêt public dans ce
pays et un accord de dimensions
colossales les médias dont certains sont
en grande difficulté financière vont
recevoir des millions de dollars
australiens de google et facebook
en échange les géants du numérique ont
l'assurance qu'ils ne seront pas
contraints de payer des sommes plus
élevées que celles négociées avec les
organes de presse comme le prévoyait un
projet de loi examiné depuis ce lundi
par le parlement australien
ce texte avait provoqué un bras de fer
entre l'australie et les géants du
numérique jeudi dernier facebook avait
été jusqu'à bloquer la publication des
liens d'information des médias locaux
en cause les plateformes internet
redoutent que cette loi donne des idées
à d'autres pays
un blocage levé ce mardi à l'annoncé du
compromis
grâce à ces changements nous pouvons
désormais travailler à poursuivre notre
investissement dans un journalisme
d'intérêt public et rétablir dans les
jours à venir les informations sur
facebook pour les australiens
le projet de loi quant à lui a été rangé
dans un tiroir
mais le gouvernement australien n'entend
pas l'abandonner au kazoo facebook et
google ne respecteraient pas leurs
engagements
l'australie n'est pas le seul pays à
avoir pris une telle initiative
le 21 janvier dernier google a signé en
france un accord cadre avec les éditeurs
de presse basé sur le principe des
droits voisins pour une durée de trois
ans google devra négocier au cas par cas
la compensation versée aux éditeurs pour
la republication de leurs contenus
mais contrairement à l'accord australien
le compromis france n assure pas pour
autant qu'une rémunération sera
obligatoirement versée